I chose this life and someday it's going  to get me killed but not today  [Music]  the rain brought on an expert in  intelligence collection and have her  hands combat agent Gascoigne was killed  last night did you know him enough to  say that he had an atomic bomb of  information and find out who's hunting  our operatives and trust no one  [Music]  David person skill content welcome to  Berlin hundun don't shoot I've got your  shoe yeah that was me from the moment my  feet touch the ground never pass the  plan this far just lying  I've lost the target  do you know that this woman has been  following me you look like you need  saving  [Applause]  [Music]  so you made contact with the French  operator obviously me on the bitch's  where the drugs  the clock is ticking and everyone you  get close to ends up dead someone set me  up someone from the inside now there's  only ends one way  [Music]  my god I think I love you that's too bad  [Music]  ah  [Music]  [Music]  you